hey guys welcome back to brand new video
we're back on monster roll against
they're gonna be talking some about the
new leaks that just came out with
potential new weapons coming to the cool
to Roth siege what they are what some of
the rarities are some of the damage
numbers see if they work well with the
other builds that possibly you can make
with these weapons or if they're better
than the current weapons in the game and
stuff like that so let's get started
with today's video so like I said these
are 14 new leaks of the weapons I'm
going to leave the original link down
below credit to Monster Hunter 88 on
reddit and SEC subo for posting these on
the DC inside.com which I believe is a
Japanese site but thank you both for
posting this stuff I'll leave the link
down below for this if you guys want to
check this for yourself I will not be
showing these photos in the in the video
just in case I do not get a claim or
strike from Capcom I don't really know
how stingy they're with this type of
stuff so I'm just gonna keep it low-key
but like I said you can leave it in the
description down below if you guys want
to read along with me so start off it
looks like almost all of these weapons
if not all of them are going to be a
rarity 8 weapon the first is the bow and
this is a rare 8 weapon like I said with
240 damage I believe that's 10 infinity
in that is a 360 fire but it needs to
have the free element unlock a level 3
decoration and +2 defense bonus which is
pretty cool the great sword looks like
it's a 1008 damage like I said also
rarity 8 with blue sharpness 0 finis and
600 Thunder with like I said has to be
free element which is also really nice
as well plus 20 on the defense boost and
also a level 3 decorations law I
personally think so far that the great
sword is definitely going to be a must
use I'm not entirely sure how the other
great swords match up since I'm not a
great sword user but just looking at the
damage and the fact that that has so
much Thunder it's going to be a crazy
weapon using it's cool to Roth since
that is her weakness is thunder next up
is the long sword also rarity 8 660
damage with white sharpness a little bit
of blue a little bit of green but mostly
a big red bar which pretty much sucks
but it's got some white sharpness as
well 450 fire and also in his needs free
element a level 3 decoration slot and a
plus 20 defense bonus the hunting-horn
is going to have 798 it's also very
similar to the longsword in the sense
that it has white sharpness but it's
very little sharpness for all of them
but a big red bar 420 sleep and also
needs free element to unlock all that
stuff with a plus 20 bonus as defense
and a level three decoration slop the
hammer is going to be a thousand 40
damage very similar to the hunting-horn
in the sense that like I said before
with the sharpness being so low but the
red being really really high zero
offended be 300 sleep a level three
decoration slot and plus 30 defense this
time the sword and shield is going to be
following the same suit as the other two
weapons with the white sharpness but a
little bit of sharpness but mostly a red
bar 252 attack 390 fire damage but it's
going to be neat free element a level 3
decoration slot and +2 defense bonus
next up is going to be the Lance with
460 damage this time having blue
sharpness negative 10% affinity 630
poison damage and following the same
suit as before with the level 3
decoration and the +2 defense boost the
switch X is going to have 700 damage
blue sharpness 0% affinity 480 water
damage a level 3 decoration slot with a
+2 defense bonus as well the gun Lance
is going to have 414 damage saw
following the same suit with the
hunting-horn the hammer having white
sharpness but very little of it in a
very big red bar 450 ice damage a level
3 decoration slot and +20 defense boost
the charge blade dual blades and the
insect glaive are also going to be up
next and they're also going to be
following the whole same suit as what
seems like half these weapons are very
little sharpness being but that being it
white with a big red bar the charge
blade is gonna have 648 damage 20%
affinity in 300 water this will not need
a free element with a level 3 decoration
slot and +20 defense boost dual blades
is going to have 0 affinity 252 damage
and 180 fire damage with free element
needed level 3 decoration slot and +20
defense boost and with the insect live
it's going to be 550 damaged white
sharpness like I said before zero
percent affinity 270 sleep the level 3
decoration saw and +20 defense boost and
then the light bogan is going to be like
I said like all these rarity 8 247
damage 0% affinity plus 30 defense boost
a level 3 decorations law and a few
other things that are shown on here I
don't exactly know what these are
obviously this isn't Japanese and
Chinese writing so don't
really know what that means and I've
never used the lipo gun before so I
can't really tell the icon is so
hopefully someone in the comments below
can let me know and lastly is the heavy
bow gun and this is going to be 285
damage with a 10% affinity level 3
decoration slot plus 20 defense and like
I said a bunch of other things that are
coming with it but I don't know what
those are and they also showed the
customization for these weapons what you
know what's gonna come with what type of
ammo we can use and stuff like that but
I'll leave that to you guys in the
comments below just if you want to check
those out because I've no clue any of
this means or does because I'm not big
on the ranged weapon so I've never
really used them as much I'm more of a
melee type guy but yeah that's going to
be it guys let me know what you guys
think about these weapons in the
comments below
I do hope that these weapons are really
good and that they give people more
options to use in fights but I do not
hope that they throw these into the
whole pile so that we have to keep
grinding and potentially keep getting
duplicates just trying to get these tier
8 weapons what that is a good idea to
get people back in a cool to Roth
because once you have the weapons you
need you really don't need to fight the
button the monster anymore so might get
people to come back and play cool to
Roth alot more so let me know what you
guys think in the comments below but
yeah guys like the video subscribe if
you're new I cover the solo guides of
monster hunter world the event quests
every week to let you know which one you
guys should be doing and tips and tricks
to make everybody a better monster
hunter a role player and with that guys
thank you guys for watching the video my
two monsters Evo's will be on screen if
you guys want to check that out that
guy's so vigorous turd a big part in the
video peace out
you